recent events were Americans heckle
public figures and public figures insult
each other to their faces have prompted
a lively debate about the place of
civility in our country in a poll
published by one Brook shanwick this
month
ninety-three percent ninety-three
percent this is that figure of Americans
say this country has a civility problem
yes we do and 69% say incivility is a
major issue in America the number has
been increasing since 2013 researchers
at the University of Maryland I went
there found that uncivil behavior might
be contagious and that rudeness can
breed more rudeness
Helen fishers of biological
anthropologists and senior research
fellow at the Kinsey Institute joins us
to sort it all out what is happening to
us Helen and why is it happening now
well first of all we are an animal that
evolved to be cooperating I mean you
know we don't have big horns or you know
fancy fangs or big claws I mean we we
survive by cooperating with each other
and when you get a provocateur who
starts this process and snowballs into
anger I mean once you get angry
provocateur who are you talking well
probably trunk but but then the other
side has responded almost equally so you
know you when you get angry the amygdala
a basic brain region goes into action
and you drive up north a nephron and
epinephrine the adrenaline and you can
stay angry and when people get angry
they get angry back and so it's a
snowball effect and we're moving into
what some people are calling a a cold
civil war because of it it's like it's
contagious so it is contagious and they
found that I mean it's called social
contagion this is based on data
this isn't your opinion oh no no none of
it's my opinion yeah but there's a lot
of I mean social contagion is very
probably comes from one sense once again
these millions of years of needing to
stick together and build in all kinds of
social rules of what is etiquette what
is polite not only with friends and
relatives but with strangers and when
those rules are broken people get
threatened they get into this you know
this fight-or-flight response and brain
regions linked with you know civil
behavior begin to break down
you you become uncivilized like the guy
next to you and so it's becoming into
you know a lot of people that I've
spoken to have quoted Martin Luther King
jr. to me they say you can't hate can't
drive out hate while others will say you
know we should reference Karl Popper
there's a lot than the philosopher who
said if you don't fight intolerance it
will overwhelm tolerance so what is the
right balance you know it's gonna be
different at different times but what's
interesting now is that this whole
phenomenon called dominance matching and
very high testosterone people will
attack and they expect you to attack
back and if you don't attack back they
regard you as weak and then they
overwhelm your space for whelming your
space and then you get threatened and
you start overwhelming back and so and
both Democrats and Republicans are are
busy doing that to one another and you
know at this point is it going to be
possible to to take the high road when
everybody is taking a different Road I
thought one of the interesting things in
this survey was that 90% of the people
who say their workplace is uncivil also
say their company leadership is uncivil
and you see companies CEOs that it is
now they've realized it's not just
incumbent to have a good bottom line
they have to set a culture they have to
provide leadership in other ways and you
know something like 86% of problems are
at worker because people don't
understand each other and when they
looked at anger people about 25% of
people who were really angry in a
company were angry because they also had
an angry boss so once again that
snowball effect but I I hear you talking
about the brain and can we just take the
brain out of it for a second don't we
know right and wrong and absolutely good
and bad behavior that's what I'm
troubled that where you see grown-ass
people who just - who are just mean and
vulgar and vile to each other yeah and
I'm very concerned I don't know how you
tap that down well you educate people
you know I mean it's interesting that we
we were born with anger no question
about it and anger is an attack it can
be very adaptive under the right
circumstances it can save the group but
under the wrong circumstances it can be
almost a runaway kind of process and you
and so as small children you learn to
control yourself when we
were very angry you really lose a lot of
self-control you become more impulsive
there's good data on that and of course
that impulsivity we'll be into you know
involved into just attacking back and
then you'll get this snowball effect but
I think y'all the brain is important
because it's it's used to regulate
emotion and anger that your that's a
deal with humans
it doesn't always regular very well but
there's different parts of the brain and
in fact when you get angry brain regions
can overcome your thought processes and
you just get more and really impatient
thank you